hey it's Evan and today I want to share
a tool with you called HootSuite and
this is a tool I use every day to help
me manage my Twitter account now you can
use HootSuite for facebook and your
Facebook pages and most your social
media stuff but I only use it for
Twitter so here's how I use it you can
set up a whole bunch of different
streams and if you go to twitter.com to
manage your Twitter you're going to be
quickly bombarded with tons of tweets
coming in and it's just a mess and most
of the Twitter power users will use some
kind of software to help them so I store
my sent tweets here so I can see what
I've been writing and keep track of
what's going on then four key contacts
what you can do is add them to a list so
I've created a list you can see here it
says list and I've created one that's
that's for family and so here is my
sister she works at the UN and she moved
from Liberia to New York now and so she
posts what's been going on and so she's
on my family list and it's a good way to
keep in touch so anybody in my family
was on Twitter I can add them to that
list and then all other tweets will show
up here and I can scroll to check it out
you can also do searches so that's the
next one here and here I'm searching for
Toronto salsa which is a company I'm
involved with or Ron Kandinsky who's a
friend of mine and any time their name
either Ron Kandinsky or Toronto's also
show up in any tweet
I'm notified so you can use a search
here for example for your company name
for your own personal name for an
industry term that you're tracking and
anytime anybody uses that word it'll
show up here so you can easily track and
respond so here
scribble live looks like they're doing
some chat with Ron Knut Sukie my friend
and they've been posting a lot about it
and showing his name so that's why it's
showing up and allows me to write back
and say hey scribble I'm exciting Ron
Kaminski is the man give him a little
bit of props and just allows me to keep
in touch now if Ron isn't mentioned
anywhere or if you know the salsa
company's not mentioned anywhere then I
don't get notified so it makes my life
easier what I love about this is I get
it all in one place and I'm not getting
emails
throughout the day that I then have to
get back to and look at and be
distracted all day because social media
can easily take up a whole chunk of time
if you let it distract you throughout
the day
next up is another list so this one I
called baseball I'm a baseball fan and I
have on my list ken rosin Rosenthal John
Heyman who both cover Major League
Baseball at a higher level I kind of
overall what's happened in baseball and
then Tschida Bedi who covers the Blue
Jays
I love the Blue Jays so I like knowing
what's been going on so there's a lot of
trade talk now see what's happening it
just kind of keeps me on top of that
world and again any any baseball writer
that I want to follow I can add to the
list and whenever they tweet it's going
to show up in my stream here next I have
my movement students so Jen and rich are
both of my students and when they tweet
I get an update again here so they write
it to another list and these lists can
be combined you can call them whatever
you want you can have a list of your
customers a list for your prospect to
list for media list for important people
list of people who you want to follow
whatever you want so your new one just
popped up here about Danks being traded
from the White Sox to the Yankees now I
hope not
don't want the Yankees to get too strong
I'm a fan but I like the Blue Jays more
so here I can see what my students are
tweeting and I can retweet too so with
each tweet I can go in here and I can
reply or I can retweet or I can send
them a direct message or those more
options as well that can click to see so
you know i retweeted something that Jen
wrote about magic is believing in
yourself and then she retweeted it and
so I could see all of our activity
together in that stream next I have
elite authors so these are people who
are authors on my website and are part
of our leap program so we have eight
thousand plus authors but not all of
them obviously elite and so I'd like to
see what they're up to what they're what
they're posting events are going to and
again I can easily from here click reply
or retweet and get involved and respond
to them these are some clients again so
again you can have all these different
lists of things that you want to add to
it here the last ones that I wanted to
share
are these three here so business so
these are you know clients that I've
done business with again it's another
list so Dell or Telus direct messages so
these are people who write to you
directly as a private message instead of
public and again I can see it here I can
reply to them and these are
opportunities that are coming up for
some Twitter chats they want to do which
is great and then mentions and so this
is a big this is the biggest one these
are people who are writing to you and I
save this for last because usually takes
me the most work and what I want to do
is make sure that I'm responding to
everybody but again I don't want a mail
notifications coming up like crazy so
what I always do
is now these are people are using my
handle what I'll do is every day I'll
retweet somebody's mention of me and
leave a little message and then I know
where to start the next day so for
example let me so there's my face let's
go back so this is what I did yesterday
so yesterday these are all the ones that
came in so all these people are tweeting
me that's great awesome and I'll respond
they'll send a happy face I'll send I
read back to almost everybody who writes
to me even if it's just a happy face and
then I'll take one of the tweets so it's
from the quote and I will I'll retweet
it and add a thank you or happy face or
something so this is from the day so the
quote and if I go down here I'll
probably see it here so he called me got
20 we tweets so I just want to say thank
you i retweeted him so I see my message
and then I know the next day that I
start from here so I don't have to
scroll down I don't have to remember did
I write back to Allison Lee then I write
back to Bravo ho5 or not I just go to my
last week and then I see all of these
are new so these are all new that I'm
going to go to tomorrow I might take one
of them maybe you know I really like
what James said the key is to believe
I'll retweet that and then I'll know
where to start the next day so just an
easy way to make sure you're responding
to everybody and doing it all at once
every day so that's how I use HootSuite
deserve there's some more advanced tools
oh one last thing that I want to mention
is scheduling you can schedule tweets
out so you know if you're not online at
a certain time that you need a mess
to go out you can schedule it so you
click in here you write whatever your
tweet is this is my grade tweet and then
you can schedule a time and say okay I
want to go out on this day at whatever
time and I find this helpful if I'm you
know doing a radio show and I want
people to call in and I don't have time
you know drew my radio show to to do it
because I'm talking or if in the middle
of a Twitter chat and there are some
messages that I want to get out that you
know the famous quotes that I like
something that's inspiring I'm usually
so busy in the Twitter chat that I don't
have time to actually you know write
those messages out because I'm too busy
responding to people or if you just want
to schedule something advance you know
maybe you're going to do Twitter once a
week and you want to set all your posts
for the week you can just go in and
schedule it one goes out everyday to
again save you time from having to log
in so that's how I use HootSuite it's
really helping my business I've gotten a
lot of deals and sales and speaking
opportunities and contracts with big
companies through my Twitter account and
also using HootSuite if you guys like
this video let me know give me your
thoughts your questions leave it in the
comment section below
if you want me to make any follow-ups to
this with your specific questions thank
you guys so much for watching and I'll
see you soon